le grand voyage de petit Manicous ce
conte a été écrit et illustré par 110
fioles aux éditions orphies
tous les soirs à la tombée de la nuit la
famille manicou s'éveille après le repas
petit Manicourt retrouve Isidore son ami
chauve-souris ensemble il joue à
cache-cache dans les arbres parfois
grand papa Manicourt raconte des
histoires du temps passé
mais depuis quelques temps petit manicou
semble triste il ne sort plus au début
sa maman pense qu'il est malade et
l'emmène chez le docteur picouse gruff
pas de fièvre pour régulier
fait
tu es en pleine forme mon jeune ami
pourquoi ne pas aller jouer dehors
Isidore tente de faire rire son ami avec
des grimaces dont il a le secret
d'habitude petit manicou Henri aux
larmes mais aujourd'hui rien à faire
mais qu'est-ce qui t'arrive petit
manicou s'ennuie
il rêve de mer bleue de cocotiers sous
les alizés
j'en ai assez des histoires et des
grimaces assez des fruits du morne et
assez de sortir la nuit je voudrais
tellement aller à la plage bronzer les
doigts de pâte en éventail faire des
châteaux de sable mais au fond pourquoi
rester ici en un clin d'oeil petit
manicou a préparé son baluchon et le
lendemain matin c'est déjà l'heure des
au revoir sois très prudent dit sa maman
ne parle pas aux étrangers recommande
son papa
envoie-nous des cartes postales demande
ses frères et sœurs autrefois j'ai connu
une jeune mangouste en bord de mer se
souvient grand-père elle avait de forts
jolis yeux
ça suffit coupe maman ce n'est pas le
moment de raconter des histoires de
jeunesse
petit manicou sourit il les aime tous
très fort mais il est temps de partir en
route vers l'aventure
quel chaleur
je n'aurais jamais cru qu'il faisait si
chaud le jour
tiens bonjour quelle drôle d'animal je
m'appelle Théo dit l'autre et je suis un
lézard vert
belle journée non à peu près
petit manicou se rappelle des
recommandations de son papa mais Théo
n'a vraiment pas l'air méchant
je cherche la mère c'est encore loin
Théo éclate de rire un manicou à la
plage on aura tout vu si on jouait à
chat perché plutôt
c'est bien ton temps mais il faut
reprendre la route s'il veut arriver
avant la nuit une autre fois peut-être
petit manicou marche longtemps longtemps
déjà la nuit est tombée il ne sait plus
où il est il a faim il a soif le voilà
bel et bien perdu
désemparé il se blottit contre un arbre
et pleure doucement alors mon gars on a
des ennuis petit manicou n'en crois pas
ses oreilles une fleur qui parle
bonjour madame la fleur
approche moustache dit une bonne grosse
voix
prudemment petit manicou dans son museau
vers la fleur
je suis René la débrouille dit l'autre
si tu as un problème René te le démêle
Allez raconte alors petit manicou
renifle doucement et raconte tout à René
faut pas t'en faire gamin tu vas la
trouver la mère
mais il ne faut pas rester ici c'est
dangereux à ce moment un terrible
grondement retenti un monstre énorme
surgit dans l'obscurité ses yeux de feu
lancent des éclairs puis les tranches
animales disparaît engloutie par les
ténèbres
après toutes ces émotions il est temps
de dormir un peu petit manicou et René
s'installe au creux d'un arbre
5 minutes plus tard il dorme déjà
paisiblement
le lendemain René conduit son jeune ami
jusqu'à l'orée de la forêt
après l'avoir remercié avec chaleur
petit manicou reprend sa route
il a de nouveau très chaud et décide de
faire une halte voilà justement une
petite cabane sous les palétuviers comme
ces coquets partout des bouquets une
nappe brodée de jolis coussins en madras
il ne faut pas vous gêner
petit manicou sursaute derrière lui une
dame mangouste d'un âge respectable le
regard
enfonçant les sourcils
je suis désolée madame mangouste j'ai
fait un long voyage et je cherche un
endroit pour me reposer la vieille dame
Gromelle
oh ces jeunes plus aucune éducation je
suis mademoiselle Micheline et de mon
temps mais alors vous connaissez
grand-père il parle souvent de vous la
vieille demoiselle Rosie jusqu'au bout
des moustaches
soit le bienvenu mon petit j'ai
justement des tartelettes à la mangue au
four avec un bon lait de coco
elles sont délicieuses petit manicou
n'en laisse pas une miette
après le goûter
Micheline emmène petit manicou voir la
mer ils arrivent au bord d'un charmant
lagon au milieu des palétuviers petit
manicou est très surpris comme c'est
joli mais ça ne ressemble pas aux plages
de mes magazines
bien sûr ici c'est la mangrove mon petit
mais tu n'es plus très loin
Micheline lui donne quelques tartelettes
pour la route puis il embrasse très fort
ici qui touche enfin au but et bientôt
hourra enfin la plage
mais très vite ah il écoute soleil ça
brûle
oups pas facile de nager quand on est
manicou c'est la tasse
beurk elle est salée
tous ces châteaux du sable s'effondrent
si seulement Isidore était là il s'est
si bien construit les cabanes il m'aide
sûrement
tout seul ce soir-là petit manicou pense
au repas de famille à grand-père qui le
prenait sur ses genoux pendant qu'il
racontait des histoires au fou rire avec
son ami Isidore tout ça lui manque
tellement
il est temps de rentrer le cœur gros il
regarde une dernière fois la lune se
reflétait sur la mer
allons en route
quelle joie tout le monde est là pour
l'accueillir
comme c'est bon de les retrouver tous
et que de choses à raconter
petit manicou et si bien ici entouré de
ce qu'il aime et bientôt il repartira
pour de nouvelles aventures